may I have the envelope please it's just
in case I forget to ask for it lid
inside is one of the following names all
of whom have been nominated for the Best
Performance by an actor Peter O'Toole in
goodbye mr. chips Dustin Hoffman in
Midnight Cowboy
John Hoyt in Midnight Cowboy Richard
Burton in an of the thousand days and
John Wayne in True Grit
I'm not gonna tell you the winner is
John Wayne
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Wow by the non-meta to put that patch on
35 years earlier
ladies and gentlemen I'm no stranger to
this podium I've come up here and picked
up these beautiful golden men before but
always for friends one night I picked up
two one for Admiral John Ford one for
our beloved Gary Cooper I was very
clever and woody that night the envy of
even Bob Hope but tonight I don't feel
very clever very witty I feel very
grateful very humble and all thanks to
many many people I want to thank the
members of the Academy so all you people
are watching on television thank you for
taking such a warm interest in our
glorious industry good night
[Applause]
[Music]